good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is practice public
speaking over to you Warren Buffett one
of the things you would want to be sure
to do is whether you like it or not get
very comfortable it may take a while
with public speaking for example I mean
that that's a an asset that will last
you fifty or sixty years and it's a
liability if you don't like doing it and
are uncomfortable doing it but also will
ask you 50 or six years and it's a
necessary skill so I'm a big fan of
public speaking I think if you can learn
how to speak it can dramatically improve
the ability to communicate your ideas to
get your message across to grow your
business to build a team but I don't
know that I would call it a necessary
skill I think you know whatever it is
that you want to do you need to be able
to bring people on board to your idea
right as an entrepreneur it's really
really hard to have success just being a
solo person so you need to be able to
communicate your idea to one-on-one
people to group settings and then to
large group settings and your your
ability to be able to do that well will
help you grow a lot faster if you can't
communicate your ideas very well to
people it's can it be a lot harder to
get your project off the ground that
being said and again it's something that
I do you know for a living right I
massively appreciate the value of being
able to communicate ideas and be a
public speaker but that being said it's
not the only way to win I wouldn't call
it a necessary skill because there's a
lot of other ways that you can stand a
lot of other ways to win there's tons of
people who you've never heard of who are
billionaires who suck a public speaking
the thing is though if that's going to
be something that you ignore then you
have to really really really be great at
something else you have to be
off-the-charts amazing at something else
if you are really poor public
communicate
then you better be insanely good at
something else and so FEMA gets back to
that teaching a rabbit how to swim
versus how to hop you know rabbits are
great at hopping and suck at swimming
and if you try to teach you rabbit how
to swim they're gonna be average at best
did you say forget about swimming focus
on hopping you could be really really
really great and so what is that
equivalent in your life and your
business for you your talents your skill
sets
what's the hopping for you and ignoring
the swimming part I think it's a skill
that everybody should at least try you
shouldn't just write it off and say this
isn't for me this sucks I'm never gonna
be a great speaker I think it's a good
skill set if you can develop it and so
it's worth giving a shot just like
entrepreneurship I think everybody
should at least try to get that idea
that they have in their head out there
at least try to be an entrepreneur
before writing it off before you write
anything off before you say that that
food is not gonna be good for you or
that activity is not gonna be good for
you at least try it give it a shot and
see if it feels right and see if you
want to continue to push forward and
learn more on it but the most important
thing I think is a self-awareness to
figure out who you are where you really
want to focus on what you have Michael
Jordan level talent at and the ability
to be among the best in the world where
you're going to apply yourself dedicate
yourself practice hard every single day
figure out what it is that you can hop
at be that bunny for and go all in on
that skill and so the question of the
day today is I'm curious what are your
thoughts in public speaking how good are
you at speaking is it something that you
want to get better at or you're gonna
totally disrespect it and go focus on
something else I love to hear thoughts
please share it down in the comments
below I also want to give a quick shout
out to Rob Barco Rob thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one-word I really appreciate the support
man and I hope you're enjoying the route
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
Express Oh give me go
this is gonna blow away people
especially your fanbase listening you
know I speak a lot and I talk over
people and I'm loud and intense but all
of my success has been predicated on
listening whether I'm doing it with my
ears or with my eyes still I use it
probably communication which I think
you're building on what Garrett said I
think communication is - a two-way
street but being able to articulate and
communicate what it is that I'm trying
to communicate is something that I find
I focus on all day long every time I
speak how do you communicate
authentically how do you figure out what
to say and what not to say in a way
that's authentic and what Fred says and
I really believe this is true is it
starts from the fundamental
understanding that there is no truth
there's my truth there's your truth and
everything is subjective and so if you
always start from the position of this
is what I believe I don't expect you to
believe it I don't think you have to
believe it I'm not saying it's true you
can actually always communicate
authentically because if you walk in the
room and this gets worse as you get more
senior here's the answer you're not
giving anyone else any room to say
anything and if you walk in the room and
say I believe this
for this reason what do you believe if
you share your truth in that language
you give people room to authenticate to
communicate authentically and that is
hugely important to these relationships
at any stage connecting increases your
influence in every situation for the
foundation of the teaching today I want
to make sure that we really have a grasp
of why connecting with people is so
vital so if you'll go to the very first
sentence in your note - the number one
criteria for advancement and promotion
for professionals is an ability to
communicate effectively that I do
believe I think the ability to connect
and communicate so number one criteria
for success with your family with your
marriage with your children with your
friends in the workplace the marketplace
in the community if you have the ability
to connect with people if you can
communicate
connect not just communicate it takes
you and literally gives you an eye a
decided edge over others in the
advancement of what we're trying to
accomplish for example in your notes
presidential historian Robert Alec says
that the success that successful
presidents exhibit five skills and
qualities that enable them to achieve
things that others don't so he's talking
about leaders and presidents and people
what makes some achieve better than
others here's the five things they do
well number one is vision number two
pragmatism number three consensus
building the ability to put together a
team and get consensus number four
charisma and number five trustworthiness
being a trustworthy kind of a person now
what is interesting about these five
these five things that set the better
presidents apart from maybe the average
ones for the five deal with connecting
visitors are deafening they're
connecting skill the ability to to cast
a future vision consensus building
getting people to work together you have
to be able to connect to do that
charisma of course that's why people
follow the quote the Pied Piper and
Trust were the four of the five of the
skills needed to be successful as a
leader had a lot to do with connecting
so let me define connecting because
that's what this book is all about
connecting is the ability to identify
with people and relate to them in such a
way that it increases our influence with
them in other words we can identify with
them until they say he or she
understands exactly what I know and what
I'm going through and we can relate with
them until we because of that ability we
begin to increase our influence with
them and of course what do I teach about
leadership very simple leadership is
influence